hey 42 here the longest novel in the
world as recognized by the Guinness Book
of World Records is a lavish urge to
thomas purdue by marcel proust within
its pages are an estimated nine million
six hundred and nine thousand characters
including spaces welcome to RIF when
classical music is played in restaurants
people spend more money on wine at his
execution louis xvi was too fat to fit
into the guilty in 2012 the fifth oldest
tree in the world was burned down by a
crystal meth habit the smell of freshly
cut grass is a plant distress call when
you cut the grass it is actually crying
out for help the second episode of The
Muppets was called sex and violence
diamonds can actually boil they have an
absolute boiling temperature of 4,300
degrees Kelvin assuming particular
atmospheric conditions are met there are
more than nine hundred and fifteen
million ways to combine six standard
Lego bricks the boy Scout's motto be
prepared was originally followed by to
die for your country
by 2019 there will be more Lego figures
on earth than people scientists estimate
that between 1986 and 2007 humankind has
gathered 295 exabytes of data in digital
storage around the world
that's 295 million terabytes but that's
still less than 1% of the total
information stored in human DNA the
Royal Navy uses blasts of Britney Spears
oops I did it again to scare off Somali
pirates for Irish based surnames the
prefix Mack means son of and the prefix
O means grandson or descendant of Maine
following a dry spell is often
accompanied by a pleasant smell that
permeates the air that smell is known as
petrica and it's believed to be caused
by organic compounds the appropriate
response - how are you in Luxembourgish
tip-top on modern word ostracize which
means to exclude someone from a society
or group according to the Oxford
Dictionary comes from the ancient Greek
practice of ostracism where a Finian's
would force an offer of their number
into an honorable exile after a majority
vote this was often used by political
rivals to literally remove their
opponents from the sea thanks for the
view subscribe for more for teaser